make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so originally I was gonna record
cheese am but I changed my mind so
instead we're gonna explain the red-room
program from Marvel Comics and we're
probably jumping the gun
because Black Widow doesn't really come
out I think until the end of April but
it's fine at the very least it's out
there some people kind of have something
to reference at least you know getting
ready to go into the whole thing so the
Red Room program in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is super clandestine right like
we don't really know anything about it
outside of the few little images that we
saw from Avengers age of Ultron the
flashbacks things that the black widow
experienced and whatever we learned
about in the movie but in the comics
it's a lot more complex now there was
the way the Red Room was originally
depicted in Marvel Comics and then
there's the way that it changed and what
I mean by that is is when you go into
the original depiction of the Red Room
program this was basically Russia's
answer to like Weapon X is really what
it was really weapons plus more than
Weapon X right so when it comes to this
when it comes to weapons Plus it's kind
of weird right like if you read Daniel
weighs Wolverine Origins after the
events of house of M when Wolverine gets
all his memories back weapons Plus was
created by Romulus which I think was a
terrible idea
but if you go when you read Grant
Morrison's new x-men that launched in
2001 he learned that weapons Plus was
basically created by John sublime now
the reason behind it is kind of weird
John sublime was this bacterial entity
that could jump from one host to the
next but eventually learned that it
couldn't bond itself and control mutants
and so as a result of that when he got
into the 1930s in Marvel Comics and in
in terms of the Marvel Universe itself
not in the real world the technology was
available for Humanity to start
essentially containing and controlling
the mutant threat and so this kind of
broke off in two ways right you had
weapons Plus and then in the 1960s you
would have project wide-awake
but the idea behind this was that John
sublime wanted to essentially find a way
to contain and control mutants and so
the best way to do that was to
essentially create super soldiers and so
according to Grant Morrison he had
weapons zero that's not super important
what is important is that word had
basically reached the ears of of John
sublime of a guy in Germany who had the
ability to create super soldiers who had
a formula for it of course Abraham
Erskine and so what you got is you had a
Nick Fury and Howlin commandoes who were
tasked with travelling to Germany
capturing Abraham Erskine are really
like you know taking him from Germany to
the States uh and then in turn
developing super soldiers and so as a
part of this whole weapons Plus program
designed to create super soldiers that
could contain and control the mutant
population you got Captain
you got weapon one now for the most part
of speculation but the general idea here
is that Captain America what was going
to happen as World War two was a test
bet it was a question of how effective
can the Super Soldier program be the
issue is that Abraham Erskine was killed
by a German assassin and then Captain
America you know while performing
admirably during World War two was
believed to have been dead when he was
frozen in ice the idea was to take
Captain America once he came back
basically wiped his memories and then
install new memories about a fake
backstory so on and so forth and then
send him forward as as a whole new
generation of super soldiers but with
Captain America basically vanishing the
Super Soldier Serum being gone are being
being destroyed what this meant is that
weapons Plus basically went forward with
like weapon 2 and weapon 3 and weapon 4
so on and so forth all the way up to
Weapon X which of course as you guys
know is Wolverine after him came of
course like the Stepford cuckoos and
Deadpool and and phantom X and different
things like that but the long and short
of this is that around the same time
that was happening about 20 years after
really you got the foundation of the
Avengers and so as a result to this
Russia really kind of you know mirroring
the real world Cold War which is to say
the idea of Russia and I guess the USSR
and the United States kind of battling
in terms of capitalism versus communism
throughout the world the USSR responded
in kind to weapons Plus and they created
the red-room project now the red-room
project in terms of this being kind of
an answer to weapons plus what's changed
entirely with IDI Brubaker's run of
captain america and what he did is he
came along and said it's a whole
different beast now that's one of the
reasons why Brubaker's run of captain
america is so critical and so important
is because the entire spy game of Marvel
Comics was changed with Brubaker's run
and with him basically bringing back the
Winter Soldier and introducing the idea
that Bucky Barnes was basically trained
to be the guy who would do the things
that Captain America just couldn't do
right now and Bucky Barnes was first
introduced he was just some kid who
stumbled across Steve Rogers changing
into his Captain America costume and
then blackmailed him into allowing you
know allowing him to become Steve Rogers
sidekick when rube Baker came along he
said no no the way this played out is
Bucky Barnes was an assassin right he
was trying to kill torture all that kind
of stuff Steve Rogers wouldn't do any of
that so Bucky Barnes did it instead the
result was that when Brubaker brought
him back what he said was that when
Bucky was quote-unquote killed back in
the 1940s and the Captain America comics
at what it really happened is he had
basically been knocked off the plane he
was taken by the Russians and then
transformed into the Winter Soldier it
was their first real foray you know as
part of their department
and creating a kind of Wolverine s
character and so the result of this is
that with the success of the Winter
Soldier the USSR wanted to take it a
step further and they wanted to say okay
well then let's create a woman who can
be the world's best assassin and the
reality is that it made the most sense
because when you're talking about
creating a female assassin she can
achieve things that guys can't do you
know guys for the most part are I think
more easily seduced than than women are
and what this did is it led to
essentially the taking of 28 different
orphans and then in turn they were
inducted into the Red Room project to
essentially be trained to become
assassins now the reason why a Natasha
Romanoff is so interesting is because
there's a bunch of different origins for
her character and not even she really
knows what her true origin is because
when it comes to the Red Room they took
a lot of the Wolverines scenario insofar
as they would wipe their mind and
install fake memories and so they never
really knew what their true backstory
was right and the reason why is because
that was all the rage back in the day
Wolverine made that popular in a lot of
different ways right Wolverine didn't
know his own history that's what made
him interesting and made him unique you
know that's the reason why Daniel weighs
run of Wolverine Origins is so landmark
because you get the whole true story of
James Holland's character but that was
that's the reason why that happened is
because it was a popular thing to do the
long and short of this is that with with
Natasha Romanov one of the origins is
that she's actually related to the
Romanov dynasty right those ARS who were
basically killed during the rise of the
Bolsheviks in 1915 during the Bolshevik
Revolution maybe it was 1917 during
World War one the reason why Russia left
the World War one conflict because the
rise of the Bolsheviks basically saw the
ousting of the monarchy the execution of
the czars including you know Anastasia
all that kind of stuff and Natasha was
believed to have somehow been tied to
that royal family but regardless by
whatever manner and whatever means the
nature of the Red Room is to essentially
take women and then turn them into
prodigious assassins by offering like
superhuman augmentation right so
increasing their strength speed agility
offering some measure of a healing
factor different things like that and
then sending them out into the world and
having them carry out different
campaigns for any number of different
reasons well you know sometimes it's to
basically expand the sphere of communism
at least that was the idea when the
program was launched under Joseph Stalin
during and in the immediate aftermath of
World War two different things like that
and then all the way up to the modern
day if you know for what's left of the
program carrying out whatever tasks and
things are necessary for the Russian
government now the companion to the
red-room project is the winter guard
right and that's what you guys are gonna
see in the Black Widow movie you're
gonna see red Guardian he was the leader
of the winter guard the winter guard was
a
Rush's Avengers team but the winter
guard was a group that would kind of
operate somewhat alongside the Black
Widow project insofar as they would be
like the front face the public eye they
go out and do things and like while
they're doing their thing the black
widows may go in and achieve some
particular task or take out somebody or
something along those lines that's one
of the ways that it kind of worked which
is kind of interesting if you go back
and you read like 1980s Marvel Comics is
like the winter guard would kind of be
like the smoke and mirrors while all
that's going on while that noise is
being made over there the Red Room would
go and do their thing they would send us
into Black Widow but that's what made
the Black Widow so intriguing is because
you could walk into a room and never
know who a Black Widow is right never
know if like the woman that you're
talking to is genuinely interested in
you or if for whatever reason she wants
to get information out of you and then
we'll do whatever she needs to do to
achieve that and that's what made the
Red Room so dangerous is because when it
comes to the clandestine side of Marvel
you've got groups like the hand right
the hand I always talk about them the
hand is probably one of the most
dangerous groups out there the hand is
one of these organizations where they'll
send in like one of their best soldiers
right and they'll send somebody into a
room or you know they'll take somebody
out and then like guards will come
running yet like well as far as the
guards were aware this person died
somehow by mysterious means the windows
are locked from the inside the door was
locked from the inside there's no
indication anybody ever got in but
somehow they're dead right either that
or the hand takes you out in full force
right they just send like five hundred
soldiers and they go to take you out
Wolverine actually fought a whole bunch
of them but again the Red Room is kind
of one of these clandestine
organizations right and a lot of
different people have had involvement
with the Red Room for example Bucky
Barnes the Winter Soldier he had various
missions that went alongside individuals
in the Red Room he helped to help train
etosha Romanoff Wolverine did the same
thing he was a trainer for Natasha
Romanoff as well taught her a lot of
different tactics on how to fight
different things along those lines so a
lot of people who were part of that
spy game in in Marvel Comics have had
involvement with the Red Room but
they're they're pretty cool it's just
kind of Russia's super secret assassin
spy group more or less they're very
pretentious exceedingly dangerous and
pretty capable the real question to ask
here this this is the question I want to
know who would win in a fight like the
door Milosh a from Black Panther or the
Black Widows that's what I want to know
and I kind of feel like it would be the
black widows the dorm Elijah are cool
but they don't really have the kind of
augmentations that the Black Widow the
black widows have nonetheless that's
more or less than kind of explained that
that's really sort of the the nature of
them as a group just consider them just
a super clandestine spy organization
hearing out like black
sweat work missions things like that or
just sneaking in you know they they take
on all different kinds of missions
they're some of the best fighters or
some of the best shooters they're highly
capable right they're a seemingly deadly
so let's being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you guys
have more questions post them down in
the comments section I'll peruse the
comments once we get into our
explanation on the Tasha Romanoff
that's when we'll start getting more
into like the chronology of the Red Room
and how it kind of changed over the
years this is more or less just and it's
an explanation of what it is and how it
functions but yeah we all will tie that
in heavily because the Red Room is a
huge part of our history right you know
especially when you start going into
Black Widow deadly origins when you go
into Black Widow vol 3 you start getting
like a lot of these really really cool
stories that sort of focus on her
backstory and her time in the group
because for a long time you didn't
really know what the origin was you
didn't know how far-reaching it was and
you didn't know anything about the Red
Room the Red Room I don't think was
actually introduced until 1998 right so
it's interesting and it's kind of
intriguing but we'll get more into like
the nuances of how it impacts Romanoff
and how it affects her life and when we
get into explaining her character but
without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explained it make
sure you guys have the sub button and
become part of the robb poor if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later oh you guys said
peace peace I want to say thank you to
all of the new patrons who have joined
patreon.com slash comics explained I
want to give a shout out to Henry young
- Elias G David J s Jacob H Ben John H
Jason see Austin s Austin H James O
kristymatt in Jeff R Joey M Steven Z
sloth-like lu-david C John H lean and
mean that guy asked questions all the
time Adam Cajun gnosis 916 I want to say
thank you to all of you all this list is
growing all the time leave it to the
patreon
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]